it's time for another play for all
interview and it's my great pleasure to
be joined by Scott a moss of Crystal
Dynamics the Nick Fury of the studio
some would say and head of studio access
the dynamics which of course is working
on Marvel's Avengers the upcoming game
Scott thank you so much for joining us
it is absolutely my pleasure to be here
thank you so you showed off the war
table which is a comprehensive look at
the game there's been some questions
around what the game is and I think this
is probably the best indication of the
overall experience so we're gonna drill
down into some of the stuff I'm gonna
get slightly nerdy here in there and try
my best to keep it under under kind of
control but I have to start with Kamala
Khan as the main character obviously as
a Pakistani Muslim I have a special
attachment to her and so I know you've
talked about this before but I think
it's worth repeating why I picked Kamala
Khan as the kind of main character
almost for this game and it's an
interesting decision considering it's
also an ensemble cast featuring one of
the most iconic groups of superheroes
why Kamala so thank you it's a great
question because for us from the very
beginning years ago when we started this
game there was there was little doubt in
our mind that once we hit on what we
wanted this kind of story to be about
and be able to say you know Kamala had
really just come onto the scene with her
own series in the comics and 2014 and be
able to say from the beginning from our
storytelling we're like look we need a
hero that is that point-of-view
character that can be synchronized with
a player somebody who's just coming into
their own who's trying to find their way
through the world who are fans of The
Avengers who are super fans of
superheroes who actually fit into that
mold like wow this is very synergistic
of finding Kamala because she's all of
those things right it's somebody who's
trying to figure out her place in the
world not only as a Pakistani American
but also now that she's become these
inhuman powers like how do I become part
of this and evolve and understand who I
am and what I am and top of that she is
a huge fan of superheroes particularly
of the Avengers and even in the opening
story where she's visiting a day as a
young child and getting to meet her
heroes and then that expands and
explodes into the Terrigen incident that
then she gets these powers and so now
her heroes created the events that now
she is trying to go and uncover and
reassemble so for us it
so quickly synchronized into a story of
we can familiar with her we have a
perspective of a player that is very
much like hers of being a fan a superfan
and trying to fit in and then from a
storytelling of one of the biggest
biggest things about adventures for us
is it's a family that they may have
their disagreements but she's the one
who's unifying that family together and
that's just a great just base element
for us of storytelling of saying no I
believe my heroes are innocent and I'm
going to prove it and I'm going to help
unify and reassemble these folks back
together and then that natural friction
with aim starting as really noble
efforts of saying okay superheroes
clearly are dangerous and what happened
at a day let's use science to try and
save the world and protect the world
creates this very natural friction of
she's embracing her
inhuman powers and who she is in
becoming a superhero aim is immediately
saying we want to stop superheroes and
use science instead and so that that
conflict just creates this beautiful art
for us to kind of fulfill that superhero
fantasy of becoming one of those
Avengers and then becoming part of that
team that then can go off and do even
greater things together than they could
do a part how do you balance because
obviously a lot of people will be coming
to this game from a variety of comic
backgrounds how do you balance telling
that story versus telling the story of
someone like Kamala because obviously
her her come up actually hurt her the
strength of her character was you know
when G willow Wilson and son are manapua
together they explored her a kind of her
religion and her faith and her culture
and that was the main thing that really
propelled her to success it was the
first time a lot of Muslims Pakistanis
Indians whoever may maybe got to see
their own culture there how do you kind
of tack do you tackle that element of it
within the game or is this kind of more
of like a this is more about her place
within the Avengers as opposed to her
place within the broader superhero world
well certainly we want we want to
balance both and I think that's an
important point
looking at Kamala and who she is and
just as a super fan making her very
relatable and understandable is a great
entry point because even if you don't
know who these heroes are we want this
game to be for everyone so if you come
from a comics background or from films
or from TV shows or just you like really
good stories and action adventure games
we want you to be able to get in there
and say I want to go in a cool action
adventure oh who's this
oh I understand who these characters are
the more depth you have knowledge of
these heroes under history both all 80
years of it is what was even the recent
past but be able to say oh I've seen
this and I can understand that you'll
get those little kind of insider
feelings I'm like I know that characters
outfit or I know where this piece of the
old reference came from what that Easter
Egg means but in general this is
designed to be a great story of looking
at the world looking at where things
have gone what she's trying to learn
from what's happening and just playing
this great action-adventure together so
we do want to explore and actually do
reference her being a little talk about
her family talking about her history and
past there's we called documents that
you can go off and find kind of
collectibles in the world that even give
you more insights including the
fanfiction but she writes fanfiction
about her heroes inside of this world so
you will find this fanfiction and be
able to talk about and see her thoughts
on her perception in the world as part
of it and then evolving into that super
hero who she becomes at the end of it as
Miss Marvel and for us I think those two
arcs are very much a parallel story of
who she is as an individual and a
pakistani-american in this world and
then who she's becoming as that
superhero with Miss Marvel now she's
always there to stamp out injustice
we're going to talk about the format of
the game a little more in a few minutes
but I want to kind of look at villains
and the way you introduce and paste them
out within the framework of that kind of
is it fair to call this game sorry to be
reductive but destiny like in terms of
in terms of like how its formatted in
longevity and this games as a service
our thing I would say were uniquely
hybrid of many different types of cool
ideas you know we have a very specific
campaign where you have Kamala as that
point-of-view character that origin tale
for Kamala realistically kind of the
origin tale for a min side of our world
as well and her reassembling those
Avengers but really that's those are the
hero missions those are and you saw
you've seen a couple of them the Golden
Gate Bridge is a hero mission where we
actually had you play those five heroes
you know even from you know III last
year you get to say oh I'm going to
start as Thor and there's going to
become Iron Man and then I'm going to
become Hulk
that's actually a hero mission where we
have chosen the heroes we've crafted a
story in a scenario we play them but
it's telling a very specific piece of
the story to set up the next stage of
the story and even the the Thor mission
you saw in the war table once an Avenger
that's a hero mission where you're
playing as Thor that's his is coming
back to the team but you
the AI companions there with him you
have iron man in the home and you hear
Widow and come all on the radio and so
for us that is actually the types when
talk about a hero mission and how we
tell the story those are crafted
experiences to make you really
understand those heroes interject that
into the world and the story and that's
separate from kind of that expansion of
where once you've collected those heroes
once you've collected them in the main
campaign they become a part of your
roster now you can choose which heroes
you want to go play with in those Wars
on missions and those warzone missions
are also team-based meaning if I'm
Kamala and I have Hulk now in my roster
it's like I have to my heroes I can go
to any wars on with those two heroes and
choose which one I want to play and the
other one will be my a i companion and
then as you get more those other heroes
become AI companions for you so you can
play all that content single-player or
you can have your friends join in and
take place of those AIS and become
humans you have a mission match of those
but when I think about the structure
you're getting to there's a very
specific single-player story campaign is
all about reassembling the Avengers the
origin tale for Kamala how aim sets up
the world and that's just the beginning
like that just sets up the state of the
world and at the end of that campaign is
when these other areas and war zones and
story threads open that have their own
story arcs that are individual for our
Hawk or for a widow but also just aim
itself like what else is aim doing what
other things are they researching and
technologies that are threatening the
world and then we start adding new
heroes new regions that also come with
new stories and new named villains as we
go forward and so now that world starts
expanding new threats and more things
that go from hey we're just kind of
worried about San Francisco and then
we're worried more about these other
regions now we're worried about the
globe and now it's getting even bigger
and bigger as we go outside from that
yeah I guess my my line of thinking was
like how do you make those war zone
style
missions impactful when you know you
have MODOK like do they have villainous
kind of end points in those side ones
like you mentioned Toastmasters about
and like super adaptoid was mentioned a
couple times in that kind of war table
presentation are those characters that
are gonna be villains that also be in
those war zone experiences and how do
you make them you know it's it's weird
like in games like destiny you have this
amazing like build up to all the taken
King is coming and then you play the
game and you send back
taking King for 20 hours a time like it
feels weird to be going up against like
a high-level villain let's you know say
a taskmaster and doing within the
current like the existing framework of a
game you do those missions a bunch of
times and each time you'd end up by
being the crap out of taskmaster like
how do you kind of balance not how does
it how does Marvel even feel about that
like can you stop diminishing like kind
of like the prowess of our villains or
heroes or whatever and maybe how do you
approach that it's a great conversation
of you know in the hero missions when
you're actually first meeting some of
these these villains and where you meet
them and how they pay off in those hero
mission stories as part of the campaign
and then there are some that shall we
say make a reappearance elsewhere and
how they make that reappearance they are
part of certain chains or these threads
that you will follow in the war zone so
that then also has an impact inside the
world states so there's a again that
campaign storytelling of where they show
up how you first meet these these
villains but there you also the choice
of like I don't want to play the
campaign I'll just go into this kind of
warzone world where all these things are
like oh my gosh I'm gonna go down in
this mission chain might be several
missions in and you realize at the
beginning
oh I'm just chasing down something for
Maria Hill and the shield faction that
they want me to go on the specific set
of things and we're trying to get some
information or some special object or
gear back and the enemy like oh my god
there's a boss fight at the end of this
chain that's multiple missions in and
now that turns out to be one of these
other guys well how did he get there and
want to get there there's some surprises
in the story that I won't spoil but the
idea that it's not diminishing them it's
actually in my opinion elevating them
from yep they're once in the story that
I get a chance to see them and
introduced in the campaign and now I
have these other places where we can
find them for again I will leave the
spoilers out but for very specific
reasons that you can see some of these
guys and that's also the benefit of us
having new villains that we add
post-launch
we start getting other surprises that
pop in and start ending with wow there's
this whole this whole pantheon of
villains that starts to show up that we
have to deal with and I think that's one
of the fun things about some of the
technologies that aim is researching and
I'll just I'll leave it there I want my
ones royal I won't spoil it so one of
the things that we saw a great deal of
in this war table was four really
interesting character in terms of
mechanically speaking very different
styles of melee
flight is another thing that's super
important for him how did you I guess
without trying to undersell the
capabilities of your studio the studio
the people that you work with like you
guys are known for a specific type of
game and everything that we're seeing is
very like melee focused like you know it
invites people to think of stuff like
God of War and Platinum's games and that
kind of stuff and people might not
necessarily you know associate that with
Crystal Dynamics so what kind of work
have you put into making sure that one
that you've got interesting engaging and
satisfying combat to that they also feel
true to those characters so one of the
one of the how should I put it
crystal is known for telling great
stories right having that kind of epic
storytelling moments with this human
spirit something Marvel is known for so
that just philosophically aligns pretty
well I'm saying we want to have these
heroes they are believable that you can
fall in love with or fall in love with
all over again in our case since there
are new versions of them but also this
this amazing epicness in the world and
so we actually went out and pulled in
some amazing talent like Vince Napoli's
our combat director Vince was on god of
war most recently I've known been since
the EA days and so getting a chance to
have somebody who just lives and
breathes heroes and combats and
everything doesn't say Vince I got a
challenge for you buddy like I looking
at how certain games play is like hey
that weapon looks a lot like what Thor's
hammer should be like that would be cool
the idea of having him come on board and
say great I'm gonna start attacking this
which one should i do first like do
Black Widow first and he's like what
what like now this is the hardest one to
be able to say how do we make her feel
super and she can do all these things
and then when he did that he and his
team that we called the player enemy
traversal the pet team this this team of
just these guys are just live and
breathe it they bleed pixels and they
really dope into each hero and sit down
to the core
what does it need to feel like to play a
black widow okay what should her skill
trees be like okay what should the perks
and gear look like they fit with those
skill trees and they just built this
from that Center core outward and they
did that for each of the heroes and as
they did them I will tell you this that
each time a new hero came online from
that team that became the team's new
favor like oh my god like what it was
amazing this is crazy
oh my god Ironman is amazing this is
great and so they were just so good at
coming down to what's the core of this
hero they would put together their kind
of pitch and design up here I think this
hero should look like this feels true to
the 80 years of history or however
particularly young and old that hero was
and that she's getting Marvel on board
you know again from feedback but just
saying hey this is what we think just in
simple powerpoints all the way to now
we're gonna go prototype it now we're
gonna go play it and so when we got
folks to show up and we wouldn't even
say a word we'd have people just sit
down and start playing hey we want you
to try come on we're gonna just throw
you into this room let you play Kamala
Khan and they couldn't stop playing and
they just started laughing like
uncontrollably just smiling and laughing
like when they suddenly Canon begin and
they can grab one of these aim droids
and just smash it into the ground or
like okay we got it like that's and
that's that thing for us so literally
taking it look and saying what's true to
the fiction in there to these heroes
bringing on expertise that if Crystal
certainly has a great team of people but
having somebody was just an expert in
that one field
can I see elevate that entire group into
making even better smarter choices for
how these heroes need to feel like
themselves a widow has kind of a third
person shooter with a lot of cool melee
moves and then Ironman is kind of like a
jet fighter that has multiple weapon
styles and you have Hulk you think
traditionally as a massive melee hero
but Vince also gave us the chance that
if you want to tune your Hulk to be
somebody who can grab giant cosmic
infused boulders and hurl them from
range like some kind of catapult you can
do that and so I really do think these
guys embrace that from the beginning
that it wasn't just hey we're gonna
rescan the same thing with all the same
controls like no this needs to feel like
each hero could be their own game and
that's that was Vince's core and it is
it was crazy and it was difficult and
that's just the core heroes at launch as
we have new heroes coming out that same
philosophy applies to those new heroes
post-launch what they will come out and
feel like oh my gosh this is a robust
hero that has a whole new set of skills
a whole new to the skill trees all new
gear all new attributes they can
customize so it's it wasn't in is a
daunting task but in the beginning we
knew it was the right thing to do right
and you mentioned uh cosmetics and kind
of like gear and that kind of stuff can
you explain a bit about how that system
works because as well as you know how
you earn that how you unlock it and
because you mentioned or you showed your
chassis and McBride was in there and you
can kind of chat her about getting new
stuff and fabricator and all that kind
of business what's that process like and
is it purely contingent on
in-game virtual currency or will there
be an option to you know use real-world
currency to buy other stuff in the same
way that other games do so absolutely so
separating there's a little bit so
Cosmetics
which we have a variety of cosmetics
from some of the emails they do to take
down certainly the outfits are one of
the primaries all the cosmetics have to
haves you have groups you can earn just
through play because we want to reward
players for their time so you can go
find these things by completing missions
even by completing campaign there's
unique out that you get only by
completing the campaign as an example
but that's just all earning stuff so you
can do that in war zones you can do that
in the campaign so earning outfits and
actually be able to say hey we're gonna
go to chastity and there actually is an
in-game currency that you can get that
you can discover you can find and use at
the vendor at chastity store separately
from that there are micro transactions
and a marketplace where those things you
can only buy and those things are again
all cosmetics there's no pay walls for
play there's no loot boxes and pay2win
scenarios like we're very much
fans of saying that we want to reward
players if they don't want to spend a
dime they can get the core game go off
and earn tons of cool stuff to outfit
their careers that where they want to
visually and for the takedowns but for
those who want to invest and say no
there's certain things that I very much
want or this particular outfits or
particularly detailed cosmetics that I
want we have a place for them to go do
that real world currency and micro
transactions and that's just cosmetics
all the gear and all the things that you
do for gearing up your hero which you
have multiple gear slots you have
artifacts left which is kind of digging
through Marvel history and saying here
these cool items from history that
actually can apply certain traits or
powers or perks to your heroes those are
things that you find or get rewarded for
completing missions inside the game and
so all of your gear comes from in game
and from playing and from even finding
resources if you want to go really deep
on this you can actually find resources
they can then boost certain gear
elements to keep them even more powerful
or more relevant or longer because beer
has rarity if common gear all the way to
legendary gear and everything in between
if all types of different gear with
different perks different powers and
abilities so we have an entire gear tree
and system in there that certainly just
glanced at it in the war table but
there's even more depth on that than
we've talked about yet and thank you so
much Scott for your time and the game
looks interesting I'm really excited to
see more of it I appreciate you taking
the time out to talk us through it and
for more coverage of Avengers Marvel's
Avengers excuse me please keep your eye
on and games for calm and on YouTube the
compost patch game spot we're having
daily charity streams so if you can
please tune in and help us support to
cook
great causes we've directly for black
lives matter and I'm sure we'll see you
again very soon for some more Avengers
coverage